There are no moms in One Piece and that's
a great thing.
Like, WITH Mothers, One Piece doesn't work,
as crazy as it sounds.
And I can't believe I'm saying this, but Crocodile
might actually be Luffy's mother, because
I've found a lot of new evidence for it.
BUT, I also found a number of other very possible
candidates and I'll show you just how important
Luffy meeting his mother will be to the entire
story.
I
really can't explain it, but Luffy's mother
is one of those mysteries in One Piece, that
even though they don't seem to matter at all
for the story right now, I just can't help
but obsess a little about.
There is something really weird going on with
mother's in One Piece and I refuse to believe
that we won't get to know the mother of the
pirate king himself.
What's up, my name is Manu, and just like
you I assume, my mom means the world to me.
Of course there are exceptions to this, but
generally I think mom's score pretty pretty
high on the 'things-people-tend-to-love-no-matter-what'
list.
And so today I finally have the chance to
talk about something that has bothered me
for a while now.
You know how Shounen characters all seem to
suffer from bad 'I-have-no-dad' syndrome?
Well One Piece takes that a step further.
Here everyone seems to suffer from 'Wait-what-I-don't-even
-get-a-mom' syndrome as well.
And as it turns out there is actually a reason
for that, that I think is important to discuss
before getting into Luffy's mom specifically.
Okay, how do I put this: There are no mothers
in One Piece.
That's a weirder sentence to say out loud
than I thought it would be.
But it's an undeniable fact.
None of the straw hats has a mother as of
now.
Luffy, Zoro and Jinbe never have mentioned
their parents.
Franky and Chopper got abandoned by theirs.
Brook's parents must be dead, because he's
a grandpa.
And Robin, Usopp, Sanji and Nami have lost
their mothers under the most tragic circumstances.
And what I just realized is that those four
share very similar arcs.
All their mothers were incredibly kind and
brave people that inherited that kindness
to their child.
All of them then had the most terrible and
lonely childhoods after losing their mother,
suffering under a terrible lack of self confidence.
And all four of them were the ones that opposed
Luffy out of that sense that they were not
worth anything and in the end under tears
accepted luffy's unconditional love for them.
[]
And now that I think about it, you can actually
spin that in the other direction as well.
Chopper and Franky are the most quirky members
of the crew, the 'non-normals', not because
they are a cyborg and a reindeer, but because
they were abandoned.
Only now fitting in with a crew that accepts
them.
And lastly the four members that don't seem
to have a tragic backstory with their moms,
at least yet, are the four emotionally most
stable ones.
Luffy, Zoro, Brook and Jinbe I feel share
that aura of stability and groundedness.
Now Zoro does clearly have some issues of
his own, that probably relate to growing up
without parents and always fighting ever since
he was a kid.
I hope we'll get to meet his parents soon.
Jinbe's darkness stems from the discrimination
of his people overall.
And brook's is spending such a long time alone.
But I find it beyond interesting that there
seems to be a clear pattern connected to mothers
in the story.
And so it was no big surprise to find out
that this lack of motherly care was not an
accident, but something consciously decided
by author Eiichiro Oda.
As he explained in an SBS, mothers for him
are the opposite of adventure.
They take care of their children and protect
them from going on a journey that might well
cost them their lives.
And so you can't have a great pirate adventure
with loving moms around.
Now this statement may sound very trivial,
but when you stop and think about what we
just discussed about the straw hats, Oda took
great care to include the negative implications
of not having a mom into consideration.
The most tragic backstories are related to
losing a mom or being abandoned by one.
Either bringing out the best or worst in people.
For example Dofi and Corazon.
And you see it with everyone, Ace, Sabo, Law.
Oda knows that mothers are important, but
was smart enough to keep them out of his adventure
story, which will be very important later,
when we will look at the possible candidates
for Luffy's mom.
And wether he was aware of all the fantastic
effects this would have or not as a 20 year
old, I think this decision has contributed
immensely to why One Piece works so well as
a story.
Think about it, while you might at first glance
go fully woke and say 'Oda doesn't like women',
in truth loving mothers are something extremely
treasured and rare in this world.
If you have a loving mother you have won the
ultimate jackpot, you can live a happy life
away from violence and hate.
And so the fact that there literally are no
loving mothers in One Piece, motivates the
entire story.
Seriously.
All the characters now have motivation and
reason to become pirates.
They all have the potential to be saved by
Luffy, because he gives them that unconditional
love, they are supposed to get from their
moms.
As a result, crews like Luffy's or Whitebeards
are the real loving families in One Piece,
because there are no regular loving ones.
And why brotherly bonds like that of Luffy,
Sabo and Ace or that of Noriko and Nami are
more common than having actual siblings.
It's why crews like Doflamingo's exist, where
characters like baby five try to find some
twisted sense of love
and belonging.
Or Big Mom's crew, who is a caricature and
dark twist on the concept of a loving mother.
A woman so overly obsessed with creating a
big family for everyone in the world and so
scarred by being *cough cough* abandoned by
her mother caramel, that she ironically lost
sight of her actual children, using them as
tools.
As Oda says, real loving Mom's are the opposite
of adventure and pirates.
But I think it goes even further than that.
The fact that there are no mothers in One
Piece and all the tragedy that comes with
it, is in a way the biggest reason why this
world is broken and needs to change.
A world in which pirate crews and revolutionary
armies and marines are the only family people
can have, many of them emotionally scared,
is a world that needs to change.
I strongly believe that the dawn Luffy needs
to bring has to shine on a world where kids
can grow up in the arms of their mothers,
not having to fight.
Oh wow.
I really went deep on this one huh.
But I really love how deep one piece always
turns out to be when you dig just little beneath
the surface.
Before we get into Luffy's mom now, if you
enjoy these kind of deep dives AND some good
theories on top, I'd appreciate it immensely
if you considered subscribing to the channel
for more weekly one piece content like this.
Okay, so - Luffy's mom: It's difficult to
talk about who and where she might be, because
Luffy does have a step mom of sorts.
Dadan is pretty much Luffy's loving mother
figure, that, while tough, raised him in a
caring home.
And Luffy loves Dadan back like a son, even
if he doesn't see her as a literal mom.
In a way you could even argue that Luffy might
be so incredibly special in this world BECAUSE
he grew up with a loving, if violent, family
of bandits, his two brothers and garp.
So why do I think that after all that, Luffy
even needs a mom and that we will definitely
meet her in the story?
Well some of it comes from Oda himself - in
very tiny bites and bits, as always.
He himself told us that she is still alive
and that he has already drawn her.
But on top of that, we just discussed that
Oda actually thinks so highly of motherly
characters and their influence, that he concisely
decided to keep her away from Luffy.
He described it as Luffy starting his adventure
the moment he left his parents arms.
What I personally think Oda is hinting at
with this, is that we will only meet Luffy's
mother at the end of the story.
Actually, no, WE might ALREADY find out sooner
than Luffy, but Luffy himself will only meet
his mother towards the end.
When his adventure is over.
I've talked about this before, but I like
to think that Luffy's adventure ends with
finding the one piece, and that the big war
that must follow after is in a way a separate
or new story.
So I to me it would make sense if he met his
mom after reaching laugh tale, but before
the final big war or showdown.
I know people really don't like the idea of
the straw hats being special or Luffy being
the chosen one, because I guess they feel
like it would undermine his achievements.
And I have bad and good news for you.
Because Luffy is definitely the chosen one,
but that doesn't take away anything from all
he has accomplished.
Luffy's choices and all he has worked for
matters.
It's just that being born special, gave him
the chance to reach his full potential int
he first place.
But it was up to Luffy to live up to this
potential.
Same goes for characters like Sanji or Zoro,
who we now know also come from unique and
special circumstances.
But because they all have to work hard and
sacrifice a lot to reach the level they are
at now anyways, I think it doesn't take away
at all from their achievements.
My point here, is that Luffy, the grandson
of the strongest marines and son of the leader
of the revolutionary army, definitely will
have a special mother.
No question about it.
The only question we now have to answer, and
boy it's a big one, is, who?
Who is Luffy's mom?
So, I now want to run through all the possible
candidates we have so far.
And you might be surprised about the last
character I propose here.
One of the most popular theories out there
is the forbidden love theory.
The idea here, is that Dragon met a celestial
dragon, and after spending more and more time
together, a romance begins to blossom.
This would be a classic, bird in the golden
cage scenario, where the woman yearns for
the same sort of freedom that Dragon enjoys
and at some point they have a baby together.
As the other celstial dragons find out, the
is tortured and ultimately killed for mixing
royal blood with that of a commoner.
This, plus all the other knowledge about the
rulers of the world he now has gathered, motivates
Dragon to form the revolutionary army.
He hands off Luffy to Garp and dedicates his
life to taking down the world nobles.
I personally think, this theory is pretty
reasonable and straight forward.
It's a classic forbidden love - Romeo and
Juliet sort of approach, that would motivate
dragon, but also give luffy some unique background
that might be important towards the end of
the story.
It doesn't blow me away, but it's solid.
Another candidate is Bello Betty, one of the
commanders of the revolutionary army.
Which seems to fit quite well.
Betty is the commander of the East Blue, which
is where Luffy grew up and her abilities to
boost up peoples will and rally them to her
cause is something she shares with our hero.
On top of that, since Oda mentioned that he
would draw luffs parents in volume 45, people
have been speculating that this woman here
might be Luffy's mom.
And that might just be an early version of
Betty for all we know.
This theory does something, no other can,
which is bringing Dragon and his partner close
together and have them work towards a common
goal.
It also fits with Oda telling us that she
is still alive.
I would actually enjoy this one a lot.
Betty is no regular character, but also not
someone overly famous and mysterious.
Just someone fighting the government alongside
Dragon.
Pretty decent.
A very short theory, is that Luffy's mom was
actually Rogers sister.
That idea is based on the fact that D's seem
to have kids with other Ds.
That goes for Ace, the only person we know
both parents of.
But Jaguar D. Saul also mentioned that everyone
in his family was a D. So if it takes two
Ds to make the one who can bring the dawn,
Luffy's mother would also have to be a D.
This could be true if she was Garps daughter,
but if not, what better family for Luffy to
have blood from than the Gol family.
I like this idea, because it would tie luffy
closer to Roger and Ace, but it also begs
the question why no-one has mentioned Rogers
sister so far.
Now it's time for one of my favorite candidates
however.
And that is Jewellery Bonney.
She is actually a really interesting character
no matter what.
Because Bonnie's devil fruit allows her to
change her age and presumably that of others.
Her biggest character trait is her gluttony,
that mirror's luffy's own appetite like none
other.
Plus her face does look quite a lot like Luffy's.
Bonnies saved Zoro from attacking a celestial
dragon, even though she could have easily
not cared about the marines coming, and simply
disguised herself as a kid.
We also know Bonnie has some ties to the revolutionary
army and dragon through Kuma, as we saw during
the reverie.
Kuma somehow knew about Luffy being Dragons
son before Ivankov.
And it might be easy to think that she just
snuck into the holy land separately from the
revolutionaries, but since she is there to
save Kuma, wouldn't it make way more sense
for her to have come with them?
There was also this weird situation with Blackbeard
and Akainu.
On top of that, bonnie is inspired by the
most famous female pirate in history, Anne
Bonney, who escaped her execution, and was
reportedly pregnant at the time of her escape.
Plus of course Bonnie and Clyde, which would
fit pretty damn well with her and dragon.
Now, as promised, I'm gonna share my thoughts
and new insights on Crocomom with you as well.
However since this video is already long enough
as is, Crocomom will get its own special video,
that will be released 3 days from now, or
if you're from the future it's already here.
Until then, I strongly recommend you check
out my video on Luffy's father dragon as well.